ever feel like your bank laughs behind
your back every time you ask for a loan
like they smile nod then slap you with a
rejection letter faster than you can say
credit score yeah been there but what if
I told you you could bypass the suits
and snag $10,000 to5 million no gring no
BS with r Financial look let's cut
through the fluff starting a franch is
brutal you're bleeding cash on royalties
inventory marketing Meanwhile your local
lender wants your firstborn and a blood
sample that's cute but also pathetic
Rock Financial doesn't play those games
they specialize in franchise financing
you want $10,000 done you want $5
million also done fast without treating
you like a liability credit hiccups
self-employed freelancing between gig
they don't care Rock looks at the big
picture you your drive your franchise
tired of banks ghosting you after 15
meetings friends thinking you're crazy
for chasing your dream watching
competitors open their third location
while you're stuck fighting over crumbs
yeah screw that here's the deal Rock
Financial can get you funded today
$10,000 to $5 million actual money to
grow your business not fairy dust links
in the description click it get the
money own your future or keep letting
Gatekeepers own you your call